yeah sorry hello and welcome to this
video papua 29 my opponent he's got a
really low rating I mean voice standards
if there's been a lot higher right a lot
higher 25 here okay so we have a ready
system here and what is he going to play
97 think this one is correct for your
form before sometimes hard to remember
your own your own analysis right 95
Queenie to as a point let's see five run
isn't that something that I had on the
board only recently 55 this normal be
five tags tags okay let's go to five I
can actually if i take f6 this Bishop f6
that this is not doing that much
mmm taking it has had a very clear deja
vu kind of quality like a headless on
the board earlier in another game if I
take it and so Knight takes Queen takes
Queen f3 eat eggs King takes this night
d3 which is a problem knight c6 is got
93 it's not all that great night f5 is
also not helping me much so maybe Queen
to f3 then Queen f3s satin move many 20
feels like i've had this in the game
just like very short period of time ago
oh can I be 596 this kind of thing or
not
not sure how much that actually Nets
major to do that if it takes pawn takes
looks good I threaten it doesn't take it
okay um I just take it even just double
then double long the default okay I'm
down two minutes it's Roger I'm
reasonably sure that I had this stuff on
the board just very very read a very
very recently okay so Jim that's not
that great
hmm I don't know said equal am I can i
entertain some small hopes maybe if he
in immediate 494 this kind of thing then
I might have something no does it do it
okay k you will probably trade check
mikey is really a lot more has more more
active so I didn't have time to play a
3some how which might cost me check it
doesn't react at all to what I'm doing
this I thought the screen side is quite
vulnerable here cap it is vulnerable
check
almost wrapping the bishop here my night
is quick enough after Bishop Jake's c-5m
entire to catch him you should a 1 93 s
curtains I just touch the beep on him
black resigns yeah that leave you people
ate this rather carelessly I think you
shouldn't lose this ever but mm I wonder
about the opening it really feels like
I'm I had this on the porch is very
recently I'm fairly certain ahead okay
so this is not see 50 beef b4 b5 okay
yeah I'd really thought about this
wasn't this I don't remember I mean this
makes an awful lot of sense whereas the
night going in this is probably
destroyed destruction yeah that
immediately wins I think I played before
in that game this is also pretty awful
with the night iam ok this is this is
probably not that great I have this
knight c6 ideas but he's defending this
this well yeah I'm doubling here and
it's really not not anything at all yeah
probably you can take on the 644 draw
let's thought I think it's it's okay for
very long time cap here try this
still I still think he's ok I will be
5v5 would have been interesting hmm I
didn't think about that it is a good
movie it fixes this on a dark square b5
still probably a draw i mean this this
and i can i can snatch this pawn with it
ok that's a draw ok yeah five i don't
know if that is really doing all that
much and then some some way here now he
has to do history act 2 nite c forge
somehow he didn't yeah this is
immediately losing but i was thinking
that should also lose am I not winning
stuffy on the cot here like yeah I'm
winning stuff i think i was thinking
here here i should win yeah i'm just a
bit little bit confused that the engine
is just giving +1 yeah maybe maybe it
doesn't I mean okay this is just totally
losing his ending i think is it
I'm not one hundred percent sure it
should lose but I'm not one hundred
percent certain if I really windows
pawns I mean I want to advance those and
ultimately distract the king and win
both points him the engine gives
something like this is there the engine
slowing reform probably it should be
enough what okay and still has to be
done yet yeah Klump I'm just winning
winning the pawns immediately yeah that
was a fairly technical technical game
that he probably shouldn't lose but he
never slowed down from that instant move
mode ok guys thanks for watching